villégiature de bord de mer une
villégiature de bord de mer se développe
dès le milieu du 19e siècle à saint
gilles dans les années 30
de nouvelles maisons sont construites à
vers grand fond au nord et la plage des
brisants
le boom des années 50 conduite à une
extension sur toute la bande littorale
de la salle dina la plage de boucan
canot pour veiller au confort thermique
on a recours aux deux grands matériaux
typiques de l'ouest la paille de vétiver
et le cas du mais déjà utilisées dans
l'habitat populaire
ce matériau naturel est idéal pour ces
maisons dans lesquelles on ne vient à
l'époque que le week end et pendant les
vacances
cette maison de vacances devenue
résidence principale depuis une
trentaine d'années a été construite à
grandfonds dans les années 1960 la
distribution intérieure et d'une grande
symétrie une salle centrale flanqué de
quatre chambres murs cloisons
intérieures et plafonds sont tant qu'à
lui mais surmonté d'un toit en vétiver
plantes que l'on trouve en abondance sur
les hauteurs de l'île depuis la fin du
19e siècle
sept autres maisons de grand fond est un
exemple de villégiature transformé en
résidence principale sa charpente est
essentiellement constituée de filao
arbres typiques de cette région sèche de
lier portes et fenêtres sont découpés
dans les pans de murs en bon ou tressés
cloué sur une charpente en bois
particulièrement originale cette maison
de vacances a été construit dans les
années 60 par le grand architecte daniel
de monfreid
c'est l'une des premières maisons de
boucan canot